hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to do or die now this is a
quiz game I'm not on a percent sure
about what it is but it has no high high
okay that's weird
oh [ __ ] the annoying guy up who's the
annoying guys oh okay alright ah I win I
don't know what happened I don't know
what hate the fart what am i doing
where's our guy shooting robo what uh
excuse me why are you doing this to
anybody
oh god this isn't hi did everybody could
see it when you make a fart cloud that's
visible on the visible spectrum people
are gonna see it
oh that's counting your eye why oh god
that was horrifying why was that even a
thing flip the table I'm gonna flip the
table and rage because I don't even know
what this game is about oh oh [ __ ]
sorry aliens oh that's a bad boding well
poof or the alien human right
[ __ ] bicep mushroom cloud smash the
bug I don't know this is appealing my
ATV but I have no idea oh boy
it seems like a bad idea it seems like a
good oh I don't think that would have
protected from hitting the casing at all
I think I would have blown everything up
well so that's hobbies steel Robo of
love what is the square root of do
nothing okay alright I'm doing nothing
yay this is exactly like that other game
the easiest game this is not the easiest
game you don't know what you're doing
shoot the kite what I very clearly eat
eat
that's it I just gotta eat Oh cut those
out of your eye Oh gross okay whoa I did
it
new games unlock free the chupacabra I
fired the pirate understand any of this
I seem to be a little lost in the Y of
the department that I'm in can someone
please call manager I seem to be just
lost right hang on it's go back all
right
story okay excuse you where'd you why
user code I never thought I'd have to
shout that question out into the ball
Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck buck oh it's the
same thing oh it's the exact side iddin
read it last time because I hide your
for it okay taste the goat with your wig
and hide the fart I know how this works
okay good I did that clear I've done
this I dude it oh god it's a rhino this
time yeah breathing Chupacabra this is a
new one
how is that good oh I thought that was
gonna be Armageddon up in my butt
everyone cheers and makes more noise and
causes more disturbance and then
everyone gets popcorn thrown at their
head and dies I'm gonna do something oh
[ __ ] oh god no I'm sorry I didn't know
that that would happen if I did
something I apologize all right i'ma
shoot this guy true some kids day oh
here we go
yep how did I predict that was gonna
happen I ruin a kid's day that's [ __ ]
gross oh god I know that's gonna be the
thumbnail oh god maybe that's also a
contender don't get crushed and pet the
gap
okay there's also options who cares
there's also endless mode here and I
don't know a pirate
leprechaun I think Oh cat okay high five
the pirate all right uh-oh what would
happen if I'd gotten hooked why do I got
to do this again know our secret high
five is ruined
this is so stupid I love it let me give
him another high-five
oh it's captain five beard over here
ain't eat I five to keep him alive
the curse of the bloody blue and the
moon
flippity flapping it's the same pattern
why am I just high-fiving this pirate
over and over again I you think that I
would have something better to do but no
I don't have nothing better to do my
life is a sham I just do this I
high-five pirates all day every day and
everything's good in my life because
that's how I get joy it's the only way I
can get joy anymore oh you're going fast
now oh yeah oh you think you can go
faster than Ray Oh No stupid idiot dick
go fast you sonic [ __ ] you don't go
fast you go slow oh all of my bravado
it's not wasted with the men you will
let's see what the leprechauns don't get
crushed all right okay let's do this oh
no poor jacksepticeye
although what'll happen oh god he's dead
Oh No Oh I'll save you this time out son
look out there's blocks falling on
Ireland Oh God no he's alive whatever
this is the cat okay cool sure yeah
let's do this one this doesn't look like
I'm about to press okay I don't think
that was a pet that was a Stranglers
grasp that was a baby crusher grip there
and I should know baby I didn't mean to
do that cookie I'm making a concerted
effort to not bet this guy eat dicks cat
little cookie [ __ ] who stole the cookie
from the cookie jar
holy [ __ ] I'm sorry I didn't know that
that was gonna happen if I had
anticipated that I would have taken
measures to it before that I'm gonna I'm
going to I'm going to I'm high
okay time Thomas the Tank Engine looks
like Thomas might had a load too much
acid oh boy is that a flappy bird Chuck
hooked or like Chuck and Huck all right
Chuck [ __ ] oh god this one again oh
there's a ninja in your I was earning at
the cat oh I I'm a I'm an expert at
betting the cat I know all about petty
crap really the tube and kill the the
fail lovely family that was just over
the room they're dead now that guy got
punched to death three the chip I just
did this and that's you know you're
thinking my eternal wisdom I would
realize is a bad idea but okay be dead
now that guy's dead
again Oh third time's a charm maybe I
should learn from my mistakes and not
free this bastard oh well there he goes
your husband's dead again he came back
from oh boy
why is it just Chupacabra oh yeah I'm
not supposed to free the chupacabra let
me just let that simmer on the oven for
a few more minutes yeah okay I lost it's
just stuck all right here we go again
we're back on to the free and the
chupacabra let's see if it works this
time
Oh blink we did it i won
oh good I move on gross oh my mouth how
did I do that
oh so sorry kid I'm so sorry had to be
done gotta get more minigames I'm
addicted don't get crushed don't rush
the staff guy oh don't let him get
crushed oh god he's gonna okay zon okay
that Robo is dead now I guess dress the
cupcake trim the nose hairs boy those
sound like great games that I want to
play here we go dress a cupcake great
there we go there we go there we go
why does it need a straw what is this oh
you're a happy and then you died okay I
think that's a succinct ending to this
game
oh no let's not do that again well some
kind of ritual sacrifice because his
next one says Oh Oh always be oh woe is
me and what was B what a world that it
would have been if I had been able to
play the game pluck the nose hairs
oh what a fantabulous day that would
have been if I had been able to do that
but it's mobile only well I guess I'm
just bowling around until the end of
time so I won't be able to do that what
a bag of douching tree I was pretty good
as cynical as I was about what the hell
was going on in there I had a lot of fun
with it I always loved mini game games I
always loved little flash mini game
games they're always fun but why you
gotta hold things on mobile only I'm not
gonna download this app no way
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know where you
throw this down in the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]